at the heart of every galaxy
lies one of the most mysterious objects
in the universe
a supermassive black hole
millions to billions of times the mass
of our sun these giants power
astrophysical jets one of the most
energetic processes known
to physics
in 2019 the event horizon telescope
released this picture of the heart of
m87
the first ever image of a black hole a
second image
released in march 2021 is helping
astronomers understand the inner
workings of astrophysical jets
and the celestial giants that fuel them
a quasar is a massive black hole that
resides
in the nucleus of most galaxies like our
own
and is smaller than our solar system and
yet
through a variety of mechanisms it is
able to outshine
the whole galaxy around it so it is a
very mighty
engine that's very small that is very
very powerful
if you look at the essential features
of what we currently think is going on
in the tiny nuclei of these galaxies
is that firstly there is a black hole
there which has this mass
but it has one other property which i
believe to be very important
which is that it is spinning as a black
hole spins
it draws charged particles known as
plasma into its gravitational pull
these particles create a magnetic field
that ejects energy
thousands of light years into space
jets themselves comprise very hot
gas and magnetic field which together
move with the speed that is very close
to the speed of light
and following the precepts of special
relativity
that means that any radiation that they
emit will be beamed along their
direction of motion
in 1918 heber curtis discovered the
first jet
which he described in his notes as a
curious straight ray
as it turned out that jet belonged to
the supermassive black hole
in m87 so it's a rather special object
in the life of an astronomer
i was a research student in cambridge
university
in the early 1970s this was in some
sense a golden time
for black holes my friend and colleague
roman snyk and i
we came up with a process uh which was
able to extract energy from the spin of
a black hole with an efficiency of
roughly a half
and uh and then we said well maybe this
is the power source
for the jets and much else besides
[Music]
the blanford zanayak process describes
how a spinning black hole
twists its magnetic fields into coils
this motion creates a current of
electrons and positrons that flow out
from the black hole in both directions
accelerated by the twisting magnetic
fields
but until the recent event horizon
telescope image this process was just a
theory
so what we see in our image is a spiral
structure of the polarization
which tells us that the magnetic field
is also spiral
to have a blendford's niagara process
first of all you need ordered magnetic
fields which is what we see
our image is ordered and the spiral
structure tells us that there's a
component in the magnetic field
around the disk but there's also a
vertical component
which means that there is a magnetic
pressure that pushes out
gas very close to the black hole and
this is also what
the blend for geneaic process predicts
and
this vertical component we think is a
direct link to how the black hole is
able to launch
this jet it is the most energetic
process or powerful process in our
universe
these tiny nuclei
smaller than the solar system but
containing massive black holes
can produce as much energy over their
lifetimes
as the stars that surround them and so
when we ask well how is the universe
powered
yes there's gravity yes there are stars
but these tiny but mighty galactic
nuclei
are big players too and so they have a
large role in the growth of what we see
in the universe around us
you